[Music]
from Guy Ritchie the director of Lock
Stock and Two Smoking Barrels snatch and
Midge got whipped in the Bitsy's okay I
made that one up comes another magical
Disney Fantasy that dares to ask what if
poor people had upward mobility Aladdin
but with people this time you've heard
all the complaints about live-action
Disney remakes they're soulless
recreations bland corporate storytelling
and cynical risk-averse cash grabs well
yeah we should all know the deal by now
but as far as soulless cash craps go
this one is clumsily entertaining enough
to remind you how fun Aladdin is it's
clumsy Latino charming sort of or these
make you feel like you're watching
Disneyland Zagreb a sing-along stunt
show
[Music]
we go to the galaxy's edge next I want
to assemble my own jizz food
welcome to Agrabah a vaguely Middle
Eastern soundstage maid of parkour
courses parkour parkour will admire new
additions to the famous story like a
handmaid the cheney would like to friend
Jasmine's new psychic time-freezing
powers and typical Disney force
diversity they says that ins convent
yeah right
but don't worry grownup fans there are
too many changes to your precious
cartoon in fact all the characters are
still two-dimensional with the cast upon
knows who aside from jasmine will
definitely stay that way
featuring an Aladdin who didn't even
send his nipples off a Jafar who went
from over-the-top snake wizard to CBD
infuse snake oil salesman who and a
Jasmine it doesn't need some man to do
everything for because she already had a
perfectly good woman for that I'll draw
the path huh maybe she should be sold
instead at least she probably knows that
bread costs money take some bread Hey
she's stealing oh I don't have any money
board you will be until Will Smith's
genie justice best to move it up a notch
oh and don't let that teaser fool you
he's slightly less horrifying in the
finished product watch Disney trying to
recapture that Robin Williams magic by
casting another fast-talking 90
superstar as Big Willie throws jokes
dancing and auto-tune at you to another
baby
until you use your final wish to dis
make him go she let on a boat already I
think it's time that I told you the
story does that mean this whole movie is
just some BS we'll made up to get
discount Jaden and Willow to stop
complaining respect so gather the family
for a time-tested tale about lying your
way into power that would have been more
interesting if it were about Jasmine
Jafar's rise to prominence whatever
unholy union of man and beast that gave
birth to Iago I'm fine or the French guy
who either wrote or stole the story of
Aladdin and snuck it into his
translation of a thousand and one
Arabian Nights but as far as a
copy-pasted version of Aladdin with no
Robin Williams ghost it's about as good
as that could be and apparently that's
worth something like a billion some
things the end starring Robin Williams I
love lamp
DJ Jazzy men I dream of Giggy and
animals playing the drums Renaissance
the Disney Vault
they're just nuts ending arendelle's
best all right paper a rugs life and
parents just don't understand
lamp trap and three smoking wishes you
can just make the law disappear please
like it never existed does that apply to
laws of monopolies asking for a friend
good night john-boy it's my money and I
need it now you lied and I died
short-term time machines for sale only
for a limited time Michael and Helen May
30th 2020 say the date